my uh samples from my whiskey get here
today
oh okay working on this uh american
bourbon japanese blend look at you yeah
first to market we'll see
bro state you bro oh man stay hustling
in them streets y'all better go
give your flowers while you're alive
mm-hmm all that whiskey you never [ __ ]
a wild turkey
that was my life i like wild turkey well
i would get down on some wild turkey
how you said it you still miss it oh
yeah
i saw it i i i literally i drink whiskey
every night i told my girl i said when
we get back from montana i'm not going
to drink at home anymore only now
if there's something to celebrate
because we started watching [ __ ] uh
yellowstone i was wearing a cowboy hat
drinking whiskey every night because
they drink whiskey on that show yeah and
then that show stopped and i just kept
going
you get oh she goes you're gonna get
whiskey for married at first sight
you were like you kept on keeping passed
them up you messed them up
damn they know shut up yeah whiskey boy
you always been that way
net [ __ ] no you were you were long long
no when i first started this podcast i
didn't drink at all i didn't start
drinking it tonight i was talking about
like
two years ago oh i was like drinking
drinking i had brewed now in college i
barely drank
oh really didn't drink when i was in the
ufc
i didn't start drinking really rogan got
me on whiskey
i did a shot with him before uh
i did a shot with him i think he was
probably uh jim bean or
uh [ __ ] jack daniels i did a shot
with him he was like i'm telling it's
gonna loose you up you have a good set
i'm like
i just said i don't like to do it had a
great
set and i was like all right here we go
you know it was wild when i when i used
to drink
you know i would never drink before a
show like that i never did it like that
i enjoy it yeah because one time i did
get drunk and the whole crowd was just
[ __ ] cussing me out
robbie threw up on them no i didn't
throw up on them they just [ __ ] just
started yelling at me talking [ __ ] to me
were you having a bad set though man i
was only like
a minute and a half in they didn't give
you a [ __ ] yeah it was so cause someone
kept yelling
something and i was like hey you know
oh so i remember what happened so it was
a show i was doing
at this spot back in arizona called
martini ranch
and it was a bunch of bands that were
playing so i thought i was going to open
the show and this is like my fourth set
ever okay and i thought yo uh i thought
i was going to open the show for all the
bands
no all the bands played then the dj came
on
turned into little dancing and then the
dj was going to take a break
and then i was going to go what a
nightmare set up for let me tell you
i was so hyped i was on one because i
was you know
it was my fourth set and i was already
killed my first three sets before
you know and as soon as i grabbed that
microphone
i knew well they're not in the right
frame of mind everybody was [ __ ]
wasted man i remember i wouldn't blame
the alcohol
this [ __ ] that ain't the alcohol
that's that shitty crowd
oh no it's not you it was the crowd oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because then some someone was yelling
for a band but they already had played
and i was like yo they already
[ __ ] played and then uh i think i
said shut your fat ass up
it was a fat person something like that
yeah and then all of a sudden
everybody just started attacking me dude
dude i remember my adopted father was
there he's all christian as [ __ ]
they shake your fat ass i told the crowd
to suck my dick and all this [ __ ]
what did he say to you afterwards what'd
he say your adopted dad when he was like
hey you tried
you support him like that because i was
like man i'm sitting here
suck my dick [ __ ] my dick suck my [ __ ]
someone was like your dick's the joke
and i was like i don't have a reply for
that [ __ ]
so then i'm just it's off to the races
yeah
and oh then what made me mad is i get
off stage
and the people that were yelling at me
started buying me drinks
weird yes so weird they basically just
wanted you to get off stage
yeah i mean i respect that yeah yeah i
didn't even like say
bye or anything the dj's just turned on
the music
i was like that dude who got knocked out
he's all dj
i remember that yeah he's yeah dj hit me
i i saw my friend had a uh like a set
that was bad and then the fight broke
out
oh um teddy teddy uh the big teddy ray
oh what's up i did the show yeah all the
way to college
it was a fight broke out it was uh they
had good uh you're performing compton
man it was some real [ __ ] like i was on
stage a fight broke out
oh and then the
and some game banging stuff and he's
like all right come outside so we
everybody just he was like man he was in
the middle of his punchline it was
talking [ __ ]
and then he was like man come outside
then because i'll be right back
and then did he [ __ ] him up yeah we went
outside and i was like man y'all need to
do this y'all need to do this i was like
yes they do
yeah to see some [ __ ] oh you were you
wanted it but because they do kept
interrupting the whole night they were
drunk and then it was
like prior beef and then uh they were
i remember they was fighting then the
promoter wanted to like get in like
break it up and
i was like hold on time out don't do
that yet you didn't pay me
let's get that let you pay me first get
my money and then they had like a big
brawl in the street
then literally he's like all right man
i'm sorry about that where was i
and then like everybody came back and
was the crowd cool with it it was black
all black people they were there was he
made chicken with like he started
talking [ __ ] it made his set funnier
because he started talking about
yeah he broke it down and then he killed
him yeah
i don't want that to ever happen
that's why i understand compton
[Laughter]
when i got off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what this from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song